hello
can you guys hear me
we'll see yeah
come on let's let's hear if uh if you
can hear me i'm really confused i'm
using stream yard i've never done this
before
okay all right there i am
okay you guys can hear me
all right cool
all right just a sec i'm tweeting
oh my god it's happening so fast i
forgot to uh
tweet the link the hell going live
yeah let's do this
going live with
a bunch of strangers on the internet
well not strangers really
um
here we go
all right how are we doing everyone
where's the minecraft hey andrews
wizardly hey
oh my goodness can we see your dogs
maybe at the end because they're kind of
they're kind of busy at the moment but
yeah maybe at the end
wow okay so this is cool everyone's here
thanks so much for being here we got
our pancakes as promised actually i
didn't promise this but this is just
kind of
i feel like what has to happen rather
founder from daniel thank you
minecraft when all right guys
the minecraft i'm not going to be
streaming minecraft on this because
that sounds so stressful i can barely
manage like the chat and talking to
people
i can't imagine playing a game that i'm
like so bad at
um pancakes were expected where's deb
good question um deb is
gone i mean gone gone
someone said hey dad
hi
busy sleeping cool dog reveal sounds
great yeah they they've made some
appearance
now and then um mom is gone
minecraft is a stressful game
um yeah it is stressful i mean when when
one of those ender fellows
um get get up in your business
um how's my son he's
he's really horrible as people know
brandon sanderson really uh told people
about that
what am i carrying today i mean i'm
carrying pancakes
right that's what we're carrying that's
what we're gonna eat today or try to eat
um
hey whoa potato oh my goodness thank you
for um ten bucks thanks i appreciate
that oh i gotta highlight that
thank you i appreciate that um potato
is one of my wonderful
uh patrons so thank you potato and um
patreon it's it's there you can be rick
if you want to
i will i'm not explain that any further
um
i also want to thank um rosalind
who couldn't make it for the stream but
she
um sent a bit of a super chat
and is this a what is this
is this real money
i don't know how this works if this is
real money i mean holy
crap thank you that's incredibly
generous
um all right let's look at some of these
questions hi from ireland
um love your channel hope for some
people are actually sending money this
is weird this is crazy thank you guys
um i love your channel
huh don't know what that is ireland
thank you for watching guys
um ireland is an awesome place i've
never been there
but i am just gonna say that because
why not um play dark souls and watch
your soul with her yeah
i feel like i would probably cry like
for real on stream if i tried
playing dark souls um thank you
ben for being here um thank you david
thank you everyone andrew um
there's there's a lot going on in this
chat hello i'm here mr man yep
thank you crazy fan take i bet michael
will respect you more now
that's probably not true
um see can't wait to see more wheel of
time skits i'm really excited that's on
like i'm reading eye of the world right
now and that's like
i feel like every chapter i see
something i'm like ooh that would be
kind of fun to
how's my day going thank you potato um
my day is going pretty good i didn't get
a lot of sleep i was working on that
video for this morning which was total
click bait about
um minecraft but it was a lot of fun
um and um yeah i have an issue i i stay
up really late
to um to make videos i'm kind of a night
owl and then i just don't sleep at
all and then i end up
really hating myself in the morning like
now but i had two hours of sleep so
how far am i yeah i'm sorry i'm uh i
have a hundred pages left in eye of the
world
yeah uh i'm from germany it always feels
weird to say that why does it feel weird
to say you're from germany
germany is great
uh looking forward to getting into john
williams books after your
review that is awesome
uh thank you um yeah john williams is
an amazing writer butcher's crossing
stoner i still haven't read stoner
um sorry i'm kind of going all around on
the chat i hope you guys don't mind
um oh wow 138 people okay cool cool
we we can we can we can go with this um
dark souls made you cry once or twice
congrats it's really nice
um hi dad oh
videos up thank you so much so happy to
be on your patreon i appreciate that
um a lot thank you very much
videos lv is is very friendly and
posting some of the most chaotic
comments in the
in the chat uh thank you so much
congrats on 10k it's a confederate
you've done on your favorite books i
really love confederacy of dances i
wouldn't
say it's favorite but uh i really
enjoyed it i kind of want to reread it
though it's been a while
um if you put a scarf on your head and
start
aggressively stroking it that would be a
perfect nine of impression
do i have to aggressively stroke
anything i feel like that wouldn't be
really good
okay who's okay what is going on
i don't i don't know what these okay
i'm from indonesia hi thanks um
michael hi dad yeah michael is a
disappointing son he brought a skunk to
class brandon sanderson at byu
but we'll forgive him we'll forgive him
um
all right we're just gonna ignore these
um strange
absurdist comments what are my favorite
things to carry
you know my thoughts i don't know why i
said i like that i was weird hello from
india thank you guys yeah actually where
is everyone from like what
let's let's do that let's get some
engagement some interaction let's let's
everyone say where they're from that'd
be fun right
um and i actually do want to know where
everyone's from right here
man carrying things more like man
carrying daniel green on his back
don't don't tell him uh don't tell him
that
um wow people are all right
super stickers i feel like am i missing
the superstar superstay incredibly
generous thank you so much
um okay all right sorry guys i'm
managing the chat this is my first time
i'm
using this um darren thank you so much
for that uh
what are your favorite books well
where do i begin um
i don't know why i said it like that
once again uh
i love um i love the stormline archive
obviously but
i really fell in love with hard sci-fi
like classic sci-fi
back in the day um
arthur c clarke et cetera et cetera
uh the worst time to take a bite of
pancake holy [ __ ]
you know i love um isaac asimov 201
space odyssey
i read a lot of h.g wells jules verne
when i was a kid
i also read a lot of roald dahl when i
was kid but um
now i i really love william faulkner you
know he's kind of a divisive
um author but i really love like that
challenging like
literary fiction but i equally love dune
dude is one of my favorite books of all
time so
hopefully that's sort of an answer all
right let's see where people are from
california good i'm in california
argentina
italy croatia italy brazil
holy crap australia
i'll allow it i'll allow australians
here no hate to australia
los angeles area cool trent i'm um
i'm in los angeles it's my favorite as
well
oh thanks videos lv and damn thank you
um
have i ever heard of the book quality
land it's very funny almost dystopian
satire and privacy and algorithms
control our lives um
i have not but i'll remember that that
sounds
good all right um
what is this thank you
but i'm i'm confused utah utah is
beautiful
from iraq really
um western pennsylvania pittsburgh
um all right clipton sent to mr green oh
no
if you guys are clipping this for if you
guys are trying to get me to say stuff
that i
you know oh i'm so sorry i missed this
excited to try out faulkner because of
you thank you zach that's really
generous faulkner is faulkner is the
best
um i love faulkner you know if you want
to
obviously he's limited and of his time
in a lot of ways but
in terms of just experimental writing
and trying things out i
recommend like light in august it's just
one of my favorite favorite ever books
um david's in northern california yeah
i'm in so i'm in la so
all right and of course we know ben is
in england
everyone should go to ben and david's
channel because um
they're lovely um
what do i prefer uh wheel of time cover
or the newer one um i love the original
ones i actually just ordered uh the
great hunt
of the hardback because i love those um
hello from your basement
i don't have a basement i live in
california
so nice try um
hello from georgia georgia is lovely um
india i'm so sorry i'm indiana
not as cool as india sorry but
i'm kind of going up the chat now it's
weird
um atlantis
don't joke about that could be true um
bare hand yeah yeah that's
that's my brand you know
i love that delicious stuff
you want pancakes good yeah pancake go
make pancakes guys
do i like john steinbeck
yes i love john steinbeck east of eden i
read in high school
um i love i love these david and i
haven't i'd be interested i've read john
steinbeck in a while
i'd like to see how he's um how it seems
now
you should read first law absolutely am
i looking forward foundation to you
serious yes 100 um
[Music]
let's see hello from your mother's
basement
okay all right we got a bunch of
jokesters here
um my mom does not have a basement
either
and i will not tell you where she lives
um
can i make a video about my favorite
movies i saw your criterion collection
now i'm curious
yes i would love to make video about uh
movies and stuff
um always nervous because it's like a
book channel but yeah i
i'm a huge movie buff i always have been
and a huge movie snob
and i love to debate people about movies
hello from portugal
oh i'd love to go to portugal um read
the silent patient if you have a chance
it's amazing psychological thriller
yeah the silent patient is a book that
my wife
loves my my real wife not
you know the good one that's weird i
shouldn't say it like that
my wife my actual wife
they're in real life okay i get there's
like a a debra and there's
okay moving on yeah she loves the silent
patient
hot rod videos one my favorite oh thank
you so much i love um
hot rod and yeah that's a video you know
one of those videos that takes a lot of
time doesn't get a lot of views but
scroll up please i i made a really good
joke and i'm so proud
what you want okay so you want me to
stop everything
tom right you want me to stop everything
and scroll up
to find your name to see a joke okay
i'll do it
all right tom let's see how good your
joke was
all right i really can't i can't i can't
find your name i'm sorry could you redo
the joke
man carrying thing does not love moash
you can't clip that you're never gonna
clip it
sorry guys sorry
um jean-luc picard
um where do you like to shop for books
mostly online or do you enjoy
exploring used bookstores congrats on
10k thank you that is
really kind thank you so much for that
and um
where do i shop for books i love used
books i love used book stores
there's a bookstore um in downtown l.a
called the last bookstore it's kind of
famous it's a huge bookstore takes up a
whole bank
um i love shopping there um when i don't
i like shopping on thrift books
as a last resort i will order books
through other means
but usually i like to buy um
you know from my local bookstore
the real one is this team they hope
she's watching right now probably all i
know she is
um deborah is why my my wife not yours
any
jot
how okay you're lucky i don't know how
to ban people from chat
anyone named joshua does not belong here
as a movie buff i haven't read uh moving
pictures good question
got to read dresden files i got the
first one yeah iro
in in real life yeah
all right this is a book channel i'm
here for minecraft
yeah i know i i hate to disappoint
people sometimes
um have you read any star wars books
such as no but i really want to read the
thrawn trilogy there's a writer who
wrote a hero's die
i forget his name but he wrote some star
wars books i'm really interested in
reading those
um uh top five favorite movies
um i don't know i don't know that's way
too hard
i love like older movies i love
okay
well you gave me five um whatever that
symbol is that's euro right god i'm so
ignorant
you know what i'll take it and i
appreciate the sentiment so thank you
i don't know how to feel about it but
i'll take it
oh narnia is terrible what
since when hello narnia or chocolate on
my face
[Music]
um i've tried the last airbender um i've
watched some of it yeah
um jokes on you i have a compilation of
you
saying you love mush from the last
stream well
i'll pretend like it doesn't evan winter
evan winter evan winter what what
what what's going on evan winter
is a cool guy that's all i'll say
um oh my god did i skip one i'm so sorry
did i
i'm so sorry guys i'm still figuring out
how to deal with this
um i'm curious will you ever do a review
of the chronicles of narnia i love this
series even though there are some books
that aren't the best noah
thank you for the five dollars and um
i'd love to do a narnia thing i'd like
to do like a video kind of um dissecting
some of the themes maybe but
um yeah i used to love love those books
i
had no idea like i didn't really grow up
religious i had no idea there was any
like
allegory kind of stuff so it'd be
interesting to read them again now
with that understanding but i really
just thought like
i didn't see any of the religious
connections so um
have i read the gentleman bastard series
i haven't yet
i'm kind of afraid to start because i
feel like i'm going to get obsessed
so that's kind of what i'm worried about
um
oh club sandwich congrats on 10k this
guy's going to be
huge what kind of music have you
listened to recently thank you club
sandwich that is insanely nice
your name sounds very familiar and um
i listen to i'm gonna sound like such a
dad and i'm really kind of embarrassed
link the compilation don't link the
moash comp don't
um i'm hold on
what's what is my what is happening
my wife is texting me she's probably mad
about something hold on
she probably heard me say something
oh my god i missed a okay
she's she's sending me
uh i'm really bad at this she's sending
me uh screenshots of
of super chats i'm missing so darren
does your wife read not deborah but your
real one
i missed that i'm so sorry darren uh
five bucks
um i appreciate that darren wow i'm i'm
such an amateur
um my wife reed yeah she loves thriller
she loves um
fantasy sometimes but um i i would say
she doesn't read as
often as me but when she does she gets
into like a bin she'll read a lot
music i've been listening to lately
sorry to get off track um i've been
listening to
i sound like such a dad but um like the
beatles and george harrison and
i've been like um falling down a rabbit
hole with like paul mccartney
recently but i love like older i like
70s music
and i know i don't really listen to
anything new it's really kind of
embarrassing but it's just kind of like
comfort food
not that i grew up in the 70s or
anything um
where the f is joshua good question and
that's something you don't need to know
uh john does at the end no i have not um
favorite character from wheel of time so
far oh man
i love tom tom marilyn he is
oh my god i love him so much what a good
what a good glemon um we nee
we need a christian wait wait oh i made
it thank the heavens i made it love
older movies name
one out of the top of your head
uh pineapple express
just kidding obviously
um congrats again dude thank you
storybound um
can't wait for you to do your wit
cosplay gonna need a video of you
ripping stormlight characters and
costumes it
um okay want to have yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah i'm gonna get costumes
i'm gonna like
just blow all the money i i have and do
that
evan winter what okay what what is
happening what what is evan winter
uh how is he invading this chat uh wait
wife i thought deborah divorced you yeah
there's another one
i know crazy there's a new wife
uh mct has his own subreddit yes there
is a subreddit
and i've seen memes on there that's all
i'm saying
um here before 100k stream and
that is ambitious but i'll i'll yeah
um
um audio cutoff oh is the audio okay now
all right read my point evan winter
okay i'm so confused all right tom is
the best yeah i agree
videos lv thank you wow for that
what is your thing what is it dragon
crisps
chips that's nice
um tom is great yeah
tom is awesome congrats on 10k
london oh jack london yeah uh well reid
whitefang he wrote also a really
interesting book i haven't read it yet
but i've heard it's interesting called
the iron heel which is like a socialist
um
dystopian tale
um will i dress up as slave leia
maybe uh 70s music in classic rock
um do i even have a child is your son
into the dark tower
i won't answer that memory sorrow thorne
yeah that's another series i want to
read
um great question what's oh what's your
opinion on the beatles song it's okay to
leave your dog in a hot car
um it's a little overrated
favorite beetle um i kind of go between
harrison and mccartney i really love
those too
um
reading white fang the other day yeah
yeah man carrying thing discord
i don't do you guys want to discord i
feel like that's a good question because
i don't know how to use discord i'm kind
of intimidated by it
but if if if that be a fun thing i mean
i don't know i guess we can have chats
on there about
stuff uh can you show us your writing i
would i maybe
someday but i'm still working on it and
i'm kind of shy so i don't know
what is your favorite underrated
booktuber um other than
yourself um oh my god there's
well thanks for saying i'm underrated
but um i think i'm pretty overrated at
this point
um uh books by lane lanez
lanes she's a wonderful booktuber i've
been following her for a while
but there's so many there's really so
many luke edwards and um
philip chase is wonderful
i there's literally so many i can't like
my brain is going insane because i can't
think of all of them um
let's see hey
katie hey uh thank you katie that's
really nice and an interesting question
katie books is wonderful
talk about an underrated booktuber um
right here um what is the optimal pasta
shape
i really don't want to get into this
because this is going to
spark controversy controversy
and um yeah i'm kind of worried about
getting into this
um crazy fan take said you are amazing
oh
for but seriously spaghetti um you are
amazing just wanted to say how
inspirational you are thank you so much
crazy fan take that's
really really nice um
yes yes to discord yes yes yes discord
this gorgeous gorgeous gorgeous score oh
my god you guys are gonna make me do a
discord
is it true that you live in a villain
castle no
did your version of the eye of the world
come with the second prologue that
follows
a queen as a child yes it did and i was
so confused because i heard
all these great things about the
prologue and i'm reading and i'm like
this is just about like a kid in a
village
and it was really long and it was kind
of boring and it really turned me off
from the book for a minute i was like
what
but apparently that was added later i
had no idea
but once i read the original prologue i
got into it pretty fast
just bought the entirety of the dark
tower thanks to you um
that is amazing um i
everyone go read the dark tower it is so
so
worth it discord please yeah let's do it
discord discord discord
um acai why are you sighing
i'm a catalan fanfic reveal
gorb gorba is amazing i love gorb um
loyal patron right there loyal patron
you're too humbly um
has wheel of time been what you've been
expecting so far not at
all not at all um
not at all it's it's been so fun and
and really like adventure i didn't think
it'd be so adventurous in the first book
everyone was saying was kind of slow
yeah there's village and like in hopping
there's a lot of that but there's a lot
of intrigue there's a lot of
i love the conversations about the world
building that just drives me nuts i love
that kind of stuff
um sitting around the fire talking about
the world
can you you guys can hear me all right
yeah
oh so this connection is unstable well i
guess that's my fault
um what's your favorite movie um
yeah i don't know uh i really love like
the night of the hunter
it's an old uh robert mission movie um
we're going to show us your writing at
some point at some point yeah
um you're not overrated you're very
rated very correctly
that's very nice thank you uh thank you
for your video on frank herbert's
writing style being criminally
underrated inspired me to reread dune
was absolutely
that i love i love to hear that thank
you so much if i'm inspiring anybody to
reread dune i feel
really happy really happy favorite
steely dance song
no no i'm not gonna i'm not gonna get
into steely dan
on the live stream
i also i don't even i don't even know
what my favorite song is
um is it because one of my favorite
reasons i loved it
josh is a wonderful booktuber as well
you guys should go check out his channel
um and
yeah i can only read books i can only
really connect with books unless there's
a character named jake i'm very
simple uh you know i just i need to have
that kind of like jake connection i read
the sun also rises like
40 times because of this thing um
it's linguine though no penny no
no no you're all wrong you are all wrong
um how many of the dune books have i
read i've really
um i've begun the children of june
which is bad i've been wanting to read
more um
it just kind of happened that way all
right i'm so sorry i'm late to this the
world needs more reality tv adeline
swooning over cal thank you joel seth
joel star what a name that's
thank you very much and i love playing
adeline
and cal those videos are fun to make um
because the i can really feel
you know the sexual chemistry you know
and
i and i'm acting you know by myself but
it's like i i know that energy
those two
um all right audio fine on my end good
audio quality fine good that's what we
like to hear
uh when will we get a 90 sitcom about
nivani
um at some point
that's all i'll say um yeah i know those
things are fun to make honestly
but they they i don't i don't want to do
too many of it once you know i kind of
want to
spread things out um you inspired me to
read faulkner previously i never thought
i'd read him but now i'm planning on
this that is so nice to hear if i'm
inspiring anyone to read faulkner
that is incredible if you're planning to
read it in august maybe you should read
light in august
you know because that's a great place to
start honestly
um but you know just get ready for for
anything really
okay people are
all right ai the chicken that's okay
connection
thank you very much for that um and for
the um
the money um why jake not jacob
good question jacob although i feel like
you're a little biased
okay um i don't know it's just
shorter my family calls me jake
um uh
yeah there there are severe lack of
jakes and books i know it's such a it's
such an easy
simple name and we know that if you're a
protagonist it's best to have a simple
name
um is jake does that count yeah that
does count thank you
um david dude thank you so much that's
really
kind no peer pressure or anything i just
want to casually point out
that the first loss series exists maybe
you'll stumble across it at some point
also congrats again on tk thank you so
much david
yeah first law is a is a big deal for me
i kind of
uh was wavering between going towards
wheel of time and
and first law because um i've been
wanting to read first law for a long
time i'm a little worried that
i'll be a little too into it and it'll
kind of take up all my time that's why i
kind of don't really want to dive in
does anyone ever do that sometimes where
you're just like
um you know you know you're gonna get
obsessed with something so you kind of
try to plan when the perfect time is for
it um
radiohead question mark um i don't
listen to radiohead i'm i'm sorry
um please i need this
i need i needed this italian um
i don't know what i don't i don't
understand what's going on
uh funniest uh thank you thank you man
uh jake what's your favorite album of
all time mine is the gummy bear album
in stores november 13th lots of music
videos and extras i don't know what that
i don't know what it is my favorite
album of all time i don't have a
favorite album
you know i really love leonard cohen i
love the second i love his last album
um you want it darker that was a great
album
um is it a burden to be the silliest guy
in fantasy
it's such a burden my life is hard my
life is so hard
i'm gonna unsub if you don't talk about
don't don't don't unsub
don't don't do it um i
really i haven't i haven't read evan
winter yet i'm sorry i haven't read rage
of dragons it's honest honestly on my um
[Music]
libby app the library app um
there's a severe lack of gorbs and books
too that's great i would love
you know if you if you would be so kind
i'd love to put your name in my my own
book
um
you should make a list of all the books
you mentioned in video and make video
about it i try to remember but then can
that's probably true i probably should
do that
so that people can keep track of the
books that i love and want to talk about
uh roger zelazny no i haven't actually
um but i've that's a name i'm familiar
with
leiden august yeah how many times would
you have to reread a series so that it
becomes
a problem um i've reread will of time
and strong arc of around six
six times
where do you find the time that's
incredible no i don't really reread
anything
i mean that might sound weird i haven't
reread something in a long time i just
kind of like to read new stuff
brian herbert um really that's
interesting a lot of people don't like
those books
should i get into those i don't know um
i think i will i'll try them for sure
are you going to deal with the angry mob
in front of your house
nice try i know you're lying because
guess what
i'm in an apartment in a building
it's not a house on a street you'll
never find out
man caring thing is so narcissistic he
only reads books about jake and states
that he has the best chemistry with
himself
i did say that didn't i
it's true i got good chemistry with me
i love myself so much it's a healthy
thing
all right where are we at i feel like
i'm behind all right
i'm sorry in advance but your kitchen is
now on fire
i don't see it unless it's an invisible
fire
why am i so late oh lord why are you
late
that's a great question
uh am i missing a super chat
darren oh my god darren thank you so
much is that
when was that holy crap dude well thank
you darren
um does your real life hate
your fake one does my real
wife hate my fake wife uh there's a lot
of fondness there my fake wife
uh loves my real life my real life loves
my fake wife and they both
love me sort of but my my real wife is
is the best like for real so like for
real for real i
to be perfectly honest and i know she's
listening
she's the best i wouldn't have this
channel at all like she's
she literally like forced me in the
beginning because i had such low
confidence about this channel to make
videos
and she'd get mad at me if i didn't post
on time you know that sort of thing
and it was the push i needed and i i'm
really grateful because this is i've
been wanting to do this for a while but
you have low confidence if you
if you want to do like a booktube
channel it really you just have to like
chop like push out a bunch of stuff you
don't like necessarily right at the
beginning you just have to be consistent
and push it out i don't know i'm giving
advice nobody asked for this advice i'm
just on all i'm saying is that
the reason why it worked out is because
of
it's because of her so
story of isaac and everybody knows my
lender code absolutely slap yes
ben yes thank you ben you know
um all right i'm missing hold on i'm
catching up catching up
catching up all right what's your
favorite literary fiction book and
congrats on the 10k
thank you so much what is that currency
that's interesting
i don't i don't recognize that um
thank you so much um literary fiction
book
gosh i have to think
butcher's crossing is a western but it's
sort of literary fiction
i'll say that right now that's the one i
can think of most at the moment
um you need to do
a 20k lift pancake recipe reveal just
saying all right the the recipe reveal
is not that significant honestly but
maybe i can it's literally just bisquick
really boring
and chocolate chips how can they be late
this is mandatory yeah
i remind everyone again this is
mandatory all right
i'm gonna go for like an hour hour and a
half
but it is mandatory and um you know
that's all i have to say um
all right this is kind of getting
um sir can you stop eating on stream i'm
so grossed out by your mouth
sounds also evan winter
i'm gonna eat even more william
i love william though he's cool um
oh wow this is really sweet i actually
learned how to read from this channel i
got my first job and graduated primary
school today
thank you guys that whole stuff
what do you know
how do we know you're not a chondra what
thank you for two dollars i don't know
how to answer that question
but thank you um william i love you too
william um
thank you very much connor um
good advice yeah oh that's the oh that
was the chef oh
israel gotcha ari salvador uh no i
haven't read ari salvatore
as a lot of people may eventually come
to learn i'm really
underread in a lot of fantasy but that's
why i have this channel because it's
it's the genre i'm most interested in
it's kind of the genre i'm reconnecting
with
that i loved when i was a i was a kid
um
he is a okay all right again
i don't know sounds like something a
condor would say
i don't know this
chat has been moving faster than you two
will update yeah honestly this is kind
of crazy i've never had
this many people on on live stream so
it's a bit
strange but hopefully i'm doing
hopefully i'm trying to read everyone's
stuff even if i'm not
commenting on i am reading everything i
promise
do you watch a lot of movies as well as
reading books i used to watch so many
movies i used to watch like upwards of
300 something movies i used to keep
track of all that stuff
um in a really strange strange way
um yeah um
what sounds like something what all
right
love your sketches and collabs with
daniel thank you very much yeah
um if you guys haven't seen that i don't
know if you if you haven't but
i did a sketch with daniel on his
channel about tolkin
and that was super fun i love um
doing stuff with him because um we just
kind of like well we'll write a script
out
over a zoom call and then shoot it and
that's how it goes
not really in a mystery don't know why
i'm talking about it even more
um have i read 100 years of solitude
actually thank you for reminding me that
is one of my favorite books
um yeah i love 100 years of solitude
um gabriel garcia marquez amazing
amazing amazing amazing any advice for
new aspiring booktubers
um thank you james um
yeah i um
[Music]
i say just be be consistent
and do what makes you happy because you
know it's a really
there's a lot of people on booktube and
if you're able to do
something that's fun that you enjoy
that's a little different that stands
out then you're going to
find people also be very shameless in
your self-promotion honestly just
put your stuff out there people will
find it if
people can't find it unless you're you
know pushing it um
so so that's my thing and be consistent
you know have i i think have a schedule
even if it's not you know twice a week
or even if it's once every two weeks
that's fine but just try to be
consistent with yourself or else you may
there's going to be times when you don't
want to do it when you don't want to
film anything that happens to me all the
time literally like every time i
do something i don't want to make
anything or do anything
but i just have to force myself or else
it just wouldn't wouldn't get done so
that's my advice i guess
um
i love that the chat just won't let miss
born go yeah
yeah chat your face is very camcorder
90s dad it's great
um camcorder 90s dad
i see it i really
see it um
do you plan on expanding your channel
outside of books similar to how daniel
green reviews shows and movies on his
channel yeah
um i would love to do that at some point
for sure um
i love movies there's nothing really to
say there
yeah i do um
yeah i can't yeah exactly guys i haven't
read mistborn
i thought you guys knew that i do i
really have to address that again
yeah i haven't read miss born i'm going
to read mistborn i just i
got into brandon sanderson through
stormlight and that's just been
my obsession i have an interest in miss
barn for sure but you know
um do you place chess no but i've seen
the queen's gambit
does that count please re-hinge yourself
after the stream oh i'll
i'll try am i going to steal daniel
green's identity man i
wish that'd be really cool i could be at
jordan con right now
um i've absorbed mistborn through memes
and reviews
um spend the day with bram stoker or
mary shelley yeah i
well bram stoker i i loved dracula back
when i read it um
really love dracula
james thank you james for that that's
really kind
i appreciate that um you are cool
and i believe you are have a small
channel so
go show james support seriously i
you know everyone who's anyone who's
making any kind of booktube stuff or any
kind of youtube stuff it takes
a lot of time to do it and you know i
have a lot of respect for anybody
who's making content you know seriously
content quote-unquote uh stormlight
better than mistborn anyway
i don't think that's a very hot take but
it's probably
let's see am i gonna dye my hair blue
watching queen's gambit i'm sorry i
didn't mean to react that way but
i pro maybe who knows who knows who
knows guys
the things you'll do for freaking
content
watching queen's gambit is basically
playing chess yeah
um uh i watch jake's videos so i
basically know how to read
that's how that's how i like to think
about it you know like if you don't know
how to read
then it's all good i'm getting i'm
getting messages from my wife am i
missing
stuff oh i miss
videos your skits are serious i'm so
sorry guys am i missing anything this is
really
unfortunate but i i see it i i promise
i'll get back to it
um
everyone why aren't you going to read
answer book here why won't you read it
yeah
there's a lot of that i love getting
book recommendations
and you have no idea how many like books
i've learned
and understood understood but how many
people have recommended stuff to me
um through booktube it's it's insane
it's overwhelming honestly
um hey keep
kicking arse my dude you're a funny and
interesting guy thank you um really good
and kind i appreciate that and the name
is fitting
how much of nolan kubrick fincher and
kurosawa have you seen
um what an interesting grouping of these
of these
fellows um i've seen everything that all
of them have made almost
kurosawa probably a little less but i've
seen like you know the big stuff
um fincher i really like panic room i
think that's really underrated
nolan yeah nolan's nolan kubrick
you know i think if anyone who loves
movies was obsessed with kubrick at some
point
um i do love kubrick very much
especially
especially 2001.
um
i want to do booktube but i have very
few tools to raise quality
it's okay you know um i think use what
you have you know if you have a camera
then
then then go with that you um
you can you can do a lot if you're if
you're passionate if you're able to
talk passionately about a book and
people will come and watch
you know um if you have that passion for
it
um if you haven't read
stuff uh yeah i know about uh him i i
would love to read his books um
all right all right yes
yes i have seen akira
i love akira um just watch
quitting booktube scared me there yeah
sorry i'm staying i'm not going anywhere
sorry guys
no minecraft for permanently for me when
am i gonna read king killer yeah
um thank you videos lb that's very sweet
um okay
all right
i'm you know what i appreciate it
um i have a lot of time before the third
book yeah that's probably true
um that's kind of why i wait i have a
thing where i don't love to start series
that aren't finished
you know storm light's a little
different because i know like that's
going to get finished almost like
it's almost definitely going to get
finished
the stranger yeah camus was interesting
um
discord yeah i guess i'm gonna have to
start a discord i guess that seems to be
the
seems to be the thing zodiac is one of
my favorite films yeah zodiac is good
man i feel like the conversation is all
over the place it's weird
it's weird guys it's weird
yeah man has a goodest chan
chanyeol thank you
do it starter discord yeah
the way of king's ultimate reading order
yeah just read the way of kings i guess
that's the ultimate reading order
um
yeah i guess that's it you know i have a
few questions for you guys
all right what is the best stormline
novel that's my question
for those of you who have read the
stormlight archive what is the best
stormlight novel
subscriber q a oh i'll do a q a at some
point for sure
for sure
words of radiance words of radiance
words of radiance wave kings oathbringer
all right way of kings way of kings all
right all right all right
all right words of radiance i feel like
i'm getting more words of radiance
than anything
rhythm of earthbringer oh okay
gorb easily words of radiance
and so words of radiance wins thank you
gorb i appreciate that
very kindly um yeah i i will say um
words of radiance is my personal
favorite um i feel like it's the most
it has the best um
plot movement um oh did i i missed
i missed a chat hold on crazy fan take
what do you think about traveling
thank you again for that
um i love to travel i travel all
oh and i don't travel all the time but i
do love to travel and um
i went right before the pandemic i was
very lucky enough to go
travel to europe for the first time went
to italy with my wife went to
venice rome went to france paris
it was great it was amazing i love to
travel i love to travel
um wow
joel thank you um hold on
joel thank you so much uh
congratulations also why are you named
man carrying thing we literally never
hear you do any kind of manual labor
are you my dad complaining about me not
doing any manual labor
um also words of radiance yeah i think
words of radiance is is
uh consistently great
um well thank you and
should i really reveal why i'm called
man carrying thing should i just like
throw that out there um i guess you
could people could find out really
[Music]
super chats are just bribery so that
you'll have to read those comments
change my mind
hey it works
don't knock it till you try it people um
but yeah um uh yeah
man carrying thing is actually the title
of a wallace stevens poem
it is uh wallace stephen stephen's poem
while stephen's uh
that's there really no secret you can
just google it man carrying thing poem
it's very not a very well known poem but
i just loved the title so much it felt
like such a jarring
title for for a poem and i was like
this is great uh i'm gonna steal this
here's my bribe thank you videos lv
that's nice but
you know you're bribing me for me to
just read here is my
bribe and now you're caught so
it didn't really work out for you there
did it um
wallace steve steven stevens
oh no no
no no i'm not going to show my feet ever
i'm sorry guys
i can't i can't do that i have a family
i can't
i didn't see did i see any castles i
don't know i saw the um
doge's palace in venice which is amazing
i love the doges palace and we went to
um
you know the vatican that's like a
castle right
um
don't mind me slipping some cash under
the table potato
i i'll take i'll take cash under the
table i have i have no standards you
know
over the table under the table doesn't
matter
um now it's gonna feel kind of weird
though if we read the poem yeah don't
read the poem then just don't
um it's fine uh no man carrying thing
wiki wikifeet page
um you should review shrek
it's interesting very interesting
okay all right this is getting out of
hand
you don't thank you
but the bribes i don't first off the
point of a bribe is that you're supposed
to like
know what to do like i don't know what
the bribe is for
psa there's gonna be okay stop telling
people that guys it's not i'm reading
the wheel of time it's gonna be great
it's gonna be really great
talks about cell phone self public
influence of evan winter that is
absolutely true i'm so i feel like you
guys are having like your own chats
within the chat
it's getting weird it's getting
interesting though
um and uh there's like
conversations going on super chats are
supports also
that's the point it is support i really
appreciate that you know it helps me
like um
maintain the channel honestly you know
because it
you have to pay for stuff unfortunately
like
this kind of thing um but yeah i do i do
appreciate that
bribe thank you i'm just gonna keep
saying bribe
um knock knock who's there evan winter
what
okay all right evan winter i love evan
winter but
i i feel a little scared now about
reading rage of dragons
i feel like you guys are threatening me
second channel where i only played
minecraft um
i don't know if anyone would watch that
but maybe i don't know
i'm so bad at minecraft um
i have no money for bribes but i'm sure
we can work we can work something out
don't worry we can work something out um
uh is there an actual wheel in the wheel
of time i'm pretty sure it's
metaphorical chat ception
yeah there's a lot of i feel like
it's weird i feel like we do need a
discord because like this kind of like
inter chat chat is kind of getting
chaotic
and i feel like you there needs to be a
good place for everyone to chat and talk
um
how unhinged is this celebration is it
like talking to the wall and hinge or
burning cars in celebration unhinged
yeah i kind of wanted my thumbnail to
look like i was crashing my car
um hopefully it looked that way i don't
i don't know why i wanted it like that
but
it's not very unhinged the only unhinged
thing here is that i'm just eating dry
cold pancakes
off graham
would i consider getting a po box um
for sure um i um
if anyone wants to i don't know i guess
yeah at some point
um for sure but um
i don't really know how to get one i
guess i'd have to look into that huh
so much research um
i third that p.o box idea thank you um
that's
good okay maybe po box will be good you
guys can send me um
you know letters of um recommendations
so i can go to
a good grad school
what is the po in po box even stanford
what is it just post office box
will you make merch oh man good question
i don't know
what even could be on the merch this is
it's getting wild
it's getting wild guys we're talking
about merch
um um
i don't know i think um
i feel like there could just be merch
with just brian sanders on it i don't
know i'm afraid of getting into
copyright disputes
i always thought it'd be fun to do like
a caledon shirt
that looks like this the the friends
sitcom but again i don't know where
i don't want to step on any copyright um
but at some point
for sure mouth noise is you i'm sorry
guys but you know i'm a hungry man
i slept two hours last night i i got to
get my
nutrients from chocolate chip pancakes
um evan winter is coming
is he in my building is it
how do you summon fourth the magic the
ma magic
manic energy in your skits does it come
naturally to you or do you need to prep
yourself with a ritual of sorts
you know what the ritual is pure
desperation i wait until the very last
minute to film
and then i like just so scared i'm just
terrified
every time i post a video that's the
honest truth like
some sometimes i i will plan a skit but
some nights i'm just like
so out of ideas i feel terrible and i
just want to like
sleep i'm exhausted i just stay up super
late way longer than i should
i really suffer for my art you know but
yeah and then i just
put a stupid meme up and all as well
second in march cool merch
if that'd be awesome i mean if people
would would buy it that'd be crazy
a shirt with a man carrying a thing
that's an idea
that is um i could just be maybe i could
just like start taking pictures of
myself holding a thing that
people want me like you know you guys
just like say hey hold this thing and
put it on a shirt
maybe that is uh you as book characters
sitcom situations yeah maybe
pictures of me and deborah living a
happy life joshua
how many times do i have to tell you old
man
um i ask authors for marriage advice
that's actually a good idea david asking
authors for marriage advice that's
that'd be a good shirt
make a shirt okay here okay here comes
all the crazy
ideas make sure with your full catalan
fan art written on it all right
all right let's let's read some more
crazy merch ideas
this just says merch pancake on merch
face
i don't know what that means what's that
supposed to mean
pancake on merch face
um you should have a shirt that's just
filled
all your made up author names oh that's
that'd actually be a good idea like
ursula k lagoon and joe
anaconda i couldn't get any copyright
issues for that can i
uh a shirt of brando asking to join the
zoom
yeah that'd be good my requires
i thought joshua died that's what i
thought too guys that's what i thought
too
a picture of you would be funny
just a picture of me is is funny okay
look i i guess that could be good um
is man carrying things supposed to be
sisyphus um
i guess man holding a shirt on a shirt
so
there's so many options i'm starting to
realize like you guys should be my
design team maybe um
maybe on patr patreon i can i can
request
folks to input on the merch
um i have a couple you strangling joshua
deborah leaving you
a man carrying a thing leaving his home
that just has a divorce written on it
what if we just have a shirt that just
has what if we just have a shirt
that just has my face on it and under it
just says divorce
be really sad
to enter the last stage of narcissism
wear a shirt with your face on it let's
do it um
oh god it's perfect
chris thank you love your videos keep it
up thank you you know i love the
tomfoolery here
i love the jokes and the tomfoolery but
i appreciate the nice comments too
merch idea um i love things that fall
off of the grand canyon
i would be worried because there are
joshua died fell off the grand canyon i
didn't push him but there are
you know people who have unfortunately
anyone been to the grand canyon
beautiful
joshua faked his death because he's
afraid of the man carrying things squad
yeah we are
yeah what do we call ourselves ourselves
this is so weird this is getting so
weird the parasocial relationships are
just like
getting all over the place
um how difficult is it to discuss the
self pub scene regarding mr winter mr
green owes
a lot to him and that's on mr green but
i will say evan winter are you
are you a secretly evan winter is this
like an evan winter alt account that's
what i'm starting to think
shane company logo but it says suberial
instead i love that
i would be down with that um we okay
we are the thing thing
that's your that's that's your idea
i would uh so i would support you doing
anything you do
cute oh at this point well thank you
videos up thank you for that bribe
i really appreciate that and the support
of me
doing anything i don't know why i'm
slamming the table
it's getting out of hand i've had a lot
of coffee and
we're an hour in things are
things are getting weird the part of my
personality i try to hide from the world
is starting to come out
but that's the thing about streaming
live you know that that comes out and
it's scary
um hello big joshua fan here
larry i respected you
i respected you how about a cap with
your face on it says divorce on it
this was not on this wasn't unhinged
enough for you
i'm sorry
i'm joking it wasn't that unhinged i'm
i'm just a boring like dad even though
i'm
just like 23. i'm just like a boring dad
with a mustache
um yeah divorce
man man okay man need a peel box yeah
man need a po box
um i'm yeah
five out of ten not unhinged enough all
right
i'm gonna start transcribing things onto
my typewriter
so that you guys can tell me if this is
can you guys see this look at this this
is like a typewriter from the 70s
yeah i'm just randomly
i'm flexing on you guys wait you are
only 23
i know i look like i'm like a 50 year
old chain smoker
it's upsetting but i'm only 23 i turned
24
in august um
thing number three dr seussile that's
actually a good idea
i'm sure dr seuss would would love that
um
team jacob and team joshua shirts man
it's like a twilight thing
um you are trying
you try and desperately close a box
which is overflowing with minecraft
stuff
i'm gonna need to oh i'm sorry my
alarm's going off why do i have an alarm
on at all anyways
take off the hinges on your doors yeah i
guess that would be pretty unhinged
um uh divorced man with 10 000
subscribers on youtube and continuously
slips the name in during the divorce
hearings
yeah i'm just gonna be that guy now i'm
just going to be like 10 000 subscribers
you know
yes around like everyone who i know
um because that's that's what you do you
know
um apparently
when's your birthday mine is also in
august yeah my my birthday
is august 22nd august 22nd
uh
this video is unhinged if you get it to
double speed yeah i suggest people who
watch this after the fact
watch it on double speed do you have a
typewriter solely for your sketch no
actually i got this when i was like a
pretentious uh high schooler
and i wanted i thought it'd be fun and
so that's what i've done
i love that typewriter noise um deborah
flicking an
engagement ring at your face
why do you have a typewriter on your
couch because because because
it's uh where else am i going to put it
for you guys to see
oh my god it's so heavy it's really cool
i don't forget what it's called but um
what i actually have stuff written on
there i haven't read that i just write
random stuff
um
this whole channel is unhinged yeah
rick's unite yeah
rick's that's actually um the the
highest tier on the patreon there is
rick tier
so if any of you are interested
shamelessly promoting i should get
custody because i have 10 kids
subscribers that's the kind of
mental thing that's what i think you
know i'm going to tell the judge that
next time the custody
is brought up sure that says can i
please get some marital marital advice
anyone
i just want to make like the the
crappiest like most
like stupid merch
happy 24th i also have an august
birthday august birthdays unite
unite i got my typewriter after a
breakup which is the writer equivalent
of being a middle-aged man with a
convertible
that is so accurate ben
and i actually appreciate that
let brian sanders give you advice for
your birthday i wish i mean
my problems would be solved if i could
get the real brian sanders to help
um rick yes we love rick
i'll only buy merch if it's in papyrus
font
um we'll see about that we'll see about
that why did my dad
leave you
i don't i don't know your wife left you
because of this quality
is the stream like um doesn't have the
best quality let me check
oh no yeah it's not the best quality i
guess
i am a rick now man carrying bridge four
okay all right i
want to make the worst most crappiest
march you should just put a picture
of your face on it all right you said jk
i'll let it slide
i'll let it slide are you
my dad no it's 420 video quality got
what can he do what can you do maybe
because my wife is like
hogging the bandwidth maybe she's
probably
doing something
um you should ask the authors for
relationship advice but gay edition
why not um
merch idea comic sans divorce
with the heart emoji we leave we like
you even if you're pixelated i
appreciate that i mean there are 147
people here
watching you know 240p video
of me screaming at the screen
talking about merch
and divorce this is a niche i
work we're cultivating a niche audience
right now you know
um deborah's hogging all the wi-fi yeah
pretty much
no i that's that's too bad that's that's
too shitty i really couldn't do that
um what did you think of hbo's chernobyl
miniseries
i watched some of it it was really good
oh we've dogs incoming
we have dogs we have dogs oh my god
420 adds to the unhinged yeah i actually
i think so
born on august 22nd as well that's uh oh
okay
thank you thank you oh look
we got sedona
oh no you can't have pancakes what are
you thinking
everyone compliment my dog compliment my
dog
i'm waiting come on come on
kitty no okay i'm sorry sedona
how did you get custody of the dogs
all this talk of merch remind me i got
no money to buy a merch yeah and it
reminds me i got no money to make merch
um you need money to make merch right at
some point um
man carrying cute dog what a good baby i
i appreciate that
uh yeah
yes that's a pretty okay dog
pretty okay what what a handsome dog
okay oh there's another one behind me
what about this one this is buddy boy
he's very sweet
good boy
have you read okay what is this
what that's an uncalled for that's just
uncalled for
what is this good doggo thank you thank
you
appreciate that
and he looks very wise he is very wise
actually
top tier dog don't tell the other one
but this one is good or no
stop it buddy is perfect he is he's such
a sweetie
um he looks very what yeah i read that
dog was lurking
he lurks he's he's the sweetest dog but
yeah he's
he's very chill we've got
what what about second dog
all right i'm i feel like i've
cultivated a kind of conversation and
energy here that's a little chaotic and
honestly it's my fault
it's entirely my fault and i appreciate
it
and you know what this has been an
insanely fun experience i think i feel
like i don't know
you tell me i feel like this has been a
good chat and i kind of want to end it
on
a good note we saw the dogs we saw the
typewriter
we talked about merch we talked about
stuff but i think it's time for me to
actually get some sleep
and reflect on
the state of uh the man carrying thing
team the thing things if that's what
we're calling us
the thing thing because that's the
dumbest name
that i like the most so thank you
uh ending it with good quality nice yeah
that's what i that's what i love to
to see um i appreciate that
and oh did you think about getting a cat
your dogs are super cute um
are you my wife because my wife wants to
get a cat
i'm really allergic to cats um
it's been fun yeah thank you guys for
coming i'm gonna go
so thank you this has been a mess i've
loved it thank you ben for sticking
through it thank you to everyone who has
stuck
through and everyone who has um bribed
me like
are you k i didn't even think people
could bribe
didn't even was not expecting that
whatsoever
is there a moast here on your patreon no
there's uh fantasy enjoyer brian sanders
and rick
and there's like so much helicopter
activity i feel like there's a fugitive
in the area
so it's been a fun stream yeah thank you
guys fun stream later uh nice to hang
out i appreciate it for everyone who
stuck through
and everyone who supported the channel
like i do want to say sincerely this is
a 10k sub celebration
there's been a lot of tomfoolery and
jokes and nonsense but
i am truly extremely grateful for the
opportunity to have this channel
too and this is 100 sincere bye dad yeah
bribe to get cat um
that might that might work actually
we'll see thank you gorb
you're very kind and and generous and
everyone here you know like everything
um
this has been fun you know just being
able to make stupid videos on the
internet and read i've been reading more
than i ever have i feel
extremely proud of the channel and
grateful for for everything in the
support is just
immense so like thank you for bullying
me to read wheel of time and all the
other stuff i've been reading
um i really cat bribe all right this is
getting out of hand i better go
so thank you
for that cat bribe i appreciate that but
um
getting emotional now i don't have
emotions
what are you talking about goodbye man's
dad camcorder thank you
no feet reveal four out of ten yeah
that's fine i'll live with that congrats
good stream thank you
no seriously um
and yeah i'm gonna go so thank you
everyone this has been wonderful and
amazing
i'm gonna finish the pancakes probably
tomorrow
and take care of yourselves drink some
water today
uh read a book um
and um yeah just have a great time bye
everybody
thank you so much